do you have any texts from anyone that
has passed away yeah
[Music]
till she sent me she sent me like this
picture of her so currently on an IV I
said geez and she said did a flu swab on
me I have pneumonia I said from vaping
those weed pins hope you don't have that
vaping disease she said no I don't it's
pneumonia and I'm done with pins and
then my dad called me that she was in
surgery on Friday emergency surgery I
and it wasn't looking good I texted her
I love you and and she died before she
could read that some three months later
we got the autopsy report back and it
was associated with electronic cigarette
use I do have one from my mom who passed
away August 31st 2019 Ashley I don't
know what it was the guardian she just
messaged me randomly she said we need to
talk and for some reason like I seen it
I didn't respond and I said the next day
yes
so I don't know what it was about but me
my mom we don't really have the best
relationship we didn't she was heavily
involved in like drug and alcohol so she
couldn't take care of me and she was she
gave me to my grandparents really to you
know raise me and I was just so bitter
and so like frustrated and so like why
would you do that yeah I'm nourish I'm
your son let me get it so it's from my
best friend and I said yo so why'd you
do eight I was gonna ask you if you
wanted to come live with me in Idaho or
at least stay here for a while
and she said I would love that why the
sudden ask I don't know honestly it
would just be fun if you came here yeah
she passed away 20 days after that
Indiana was because she committed
suicide my my friends stand I mean I
don't know if I had anything to do with
him being Hawaiian but he's just the
most chill laid-back dude early last
year he was uh yeah he I liked Stage
four lymphoma and I said how are you
feeling Stan and he says I'm doing well
I'm going to stay one more day I have an
appointment tomorrow with my oncologist
thank you thank you for praying for me
god is good try to comfort your mom for
she's under a lot of stress
sounds good Stan I will be here for my
mom as well thank you for caring for her
we'll continue to pray for you and he
said thanks we're at the hospital with
him literally as he was taking his last
breaths and I was like you're about to
go home right now you know and and I was
just like man I'm excited for you
I died I called my sister he was at the
hospital and I remember telling her like
oh my god I don't remember the last time
I told my mom I love you and she said me
either so I would really love to tell
her that again definitely a lot more now
and I call them and I text them way more
often obviously since I didn't really
get to talk to my mom too much and I
really regret that now but yeah I called
him like every week I still send
messages to her on Instagram because her
family didn't deactivate the account I
miss you I feel so alone without you I
don't know what I'm doing and then I
said why didn't you say goodbye before
you left and then another message was I
love you sorry
she was seeming like messages like audio
messages and I'll just play one and ask
hmm that's the last time I heard a voice
and it was I don't know I found out that
she passed away
the day of and everything just like came
at once like the regret I just feel like
I should have like done way more than I
did and this sucks because I can never
physically say I'm sorry you know I'll
just apologize for just ignoring you for
so many years and just not understanding
your story like I I'm pretty sure she
understand mine so my dad had to go in
for like an emergency surgery over like
his two years of having cancer he
eventually like lost his ability to
speak and so the main way we like
communicated was through text or like
through writing and it was a really
tough transition home we were like
trying to get him settled in to his
house and his room knowing that like
eventually that was where he was gonna
be until he passed and then he finally
was like awake so I popped into his room
just to say like hey like I'm leaving
now so as I was leaving he texted me and
he said hi Taylor thank you for being
there for me it means a lot to me love
you
and he's my dad has never like super
affectionate oh so yeah I think like him
for me like knowing that he went out of
his way to like text that to me and was
appreciative that I was there was really
touching to me he knew that his time was
short and I knew so yeah that text means
a lot to me